this right here is the entire lineup of
new M3 MacBook Pros with every possible
chip configuration for a total of six
machines that we've been testing
extensively for the past month and this
video will serve as the ultimate
performance guide jam-packed with tons
of charts that feature all six on screen
at the same time this took insane
amounts of time to put together and it's
meant for you to be able to save this
video for future reference to see all of
the performance differences so hit the
like button and subscribe if you
appreciate all the effort here are all
of the specs for the regular M3 chip
machines on screen including the 8 gig
and 16 gig models as well as both the
base and upgraded M3 Pro Models and also
the base and upgraded M3 Max models that
we have been testing so let's jump right
into this crazy performance comparison
first up we have the SSD trans transfer
speeds and as you can see the M3 Pro and
Max models are quite a lot faster than
the regular M3s because they pack in
more SSD nand chips jumping into single
core performance and geekbench 6 they're
all around the same with a slight Edge
going to the M3 Max models because they
support high power mode but when testing
web browsing performance with the
speedometer 2.1 Benchmark they're all
basically within margin of error except
for the 8 gig model because it doesn't
have enough RAM to keep up as for
multicore performance you can see that
it scales fairly evenly as you go up
with the upgraded M3 Max being almost
two times faster than the M3 chip
basically making it one of the fastest
mass production chips in the world
competing with the very best desktop
chips from Intel now if you look at
multicore score per dollar using the
best chips in the smallest 14in MacBook
Pro sizes the best bang for the buck is
the $1,600 base mod model with it going
down to the worst value with the
upgraded M3 Max because it forces you to
upgrade the RAM to 48 gigs and the
storage to 1 tbte so you lose more raw
performance value so then we tested the
more realistic cinebench 2024 CPU
rendering test which factors in thermal
throttling so we actually tested the
16-in models for some of the higher end
configs and here we can see the score
increasing linearly once again again but
this time when you look at the score per
dollar spent the upgraded M3 Max and the
16-in chassis performed basically just
as good as the others except for that
crazy good value 14-in base M3 Pro chip
model so it's still worth spending the
extra cash for heavy CPU rendering
workloads we then tested web design in
figma using a project from 500 designs
one of the best design studios in
California and here it's definit
defitely not worth upgrading to the M3
Max chips with such a small difference
that the M3 model would actually be just
fine to buy but now moving on to some
realworld performance tests that can
actually take advantage of multicore
performance quite well we have logic pro
music production where the M3 Max models
significantly outperform the rest in
terms of how many tracks they can handle
at once but fair warning the 14-in M3
Max got crazy loud in terms of fan noise
while maxing out the CPU in this test so
producers are much better off getting
the 16in size since it packs huge fans
and heat sinks on the inside for better
cooling now for the programmers out
there we also tested The xcode Benchmark
which has been fully reworked from the
ground up with xcode 15 and here we're
actually getting very noticeable
improvements moving up to the better M3
Pro and M3 Max chips down to only 72.5
seconds on the M3 Max which is crazy
fast and will surely help you save idle
time it was literally so fast that it
almost matched up to the fully upgraded
M2 Ultra Max studio but it's in a
portable laptop running on battery power
which is just insane but as far as bang
for your buck I would probably go for
one of the M3 Pro Models especially
since right now the $2,000 M3 Pro 14 in
is on sale for $1,800 on Amazon and by
the way I'm going to have links to all
of the Amazon sales for all of the
machines down below and now with all of
those CPU tests out of the way let's
jump right into graphics performance
with geekbench 6's GPU test here we're
seeing some pretty massive jumps when
you go up to the M3 Max chips since a
huge focus with these ones is GPU cores
with 40 cores on the M3 Max being 3.25
times faster than the base m 3 and now
looking at score per dollar using the
less expensive 14-in models for all of
the chips since cooling doesn't really
matter in this test we can see that you
get better value per dollar as you
upgrade to better chips especially the
best of the best upgraded M3 Max which
also includes 48 gigs of RAM and a
terabyte of SSD so this is already a
killer value for graphics users so then
I tested a real world gaming Benchmark
which is 3D Marks Wildlife extreme
unlimited and here we saw even better
results with the more expensive chips
with the 40 core M3 Max now being 3.9
times faster than the bass M3 so if
you're thinking of also doing some
gaming on the side of your main Graphics
work the best M3 Max is the obvious
choice if you can afford the insanely
high price tag compared to windows-based
gaming laptops that brings us to
cinebench 2024's new GPU rendering test
and here the new app wouldn't even allow
the 8 GB Ram M3 model to run the test
but besides that we see basically the
same results here with massive
performance jumps as you upgrade to the
M3 Max models making them so worth it
for rendering so we tested exactly that
in blender 4.0 beta which now supports
Ray tracing even with the 8 GB Ram model
and here we got a massive performance
improvement with the Bas M3 Pro MacBook
Pro being over r as fast as the Bas M3
and keep in mind it's only $1,800 on
sale on Amazon which is a killer deal
but the M3 Max models just took it to
the next level rendering this party tug
project in around 30 seconds almost
twice as fast as the M3 pros and now
getting into photo editing in Lightroom
classic there were some big discoveries
here with a Bas model M3 MacBook Pro
taking forever to export due to not
having enough RAM and a simple upgrade
to 16 gigs got us down to a minute and 6
seconds but it got even worse when we
did our multitasking test with five web
tabs open making the 8 GB M3 model slow
down even more and much more with 20 web
tabs open taking over 5 minutes long so
I'm pretty much going to recommend
everyone who cares about performance to
get 16 GB of RAM for
$1,800 or better yet seriously just buy
the M3 pro model for $1800 on Amazon
since it comes with 18 gigs of RAM
faster ssds an extra Thunderbolt Port
dual fans for quieter operation and an
extra supported external display now
moving on to Final Cut Pro video editing
I exported our 5minute 4K HBC project
which is the most common format people
shoot in and the M3 Pro made no
difference at all because it has the
same encod oders as the M3 but the M3
Max actually has dual encoders so it's
much faster and yes I also tested the
brand new 10.7 update of Final Cut and
it only marginally improved the export
Times by 4 seconds across the board and
finally in the craziest export test that
we have which isn't limited by encoders
which is Canon R5 8K raw the 16 GB ram
upgrade made a massive difference for
the M3 and the 16-in M3 Max dominated
the rest of them due to all of that
graphics performance and the cooling
system so with all of that said here are
my recommendations if you care about
performance do not buy the 8 GB Ram M3
model instead I'm going to recommend the
14-in M3 Pro for 1,800 on Amazon for
basically everyone because it gets the
best bank for your buck for a great low
price now for those who aren't afraid to
spend a ton of money on the M3 Max
models in exchange for the fastest
performance you can get I'm going to
straight up recommend the upgraded M3
Max model with 40 GPU cores because it's
above and beyond everything else and it
comes with 48 gigs of RAM and 1 tbte of
SSD which are both good solid choices so
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did go ahead and subscribe above for
all of that hard effort and definitely
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next
[Music]
video